[Música]
[Aplausos]
mi mamá siempre me recuerda que a los 3
años llegue a casa con un folleto
comercial de una academia de música y le
dije yo quiero apuntarme aquí
y mi mamá sorprendida dijo no yo creo
mira hija mía que lo tuyo tendría que
ser el deporte porque tienes un poquito
de sobrepeso y bueno lo de la música
está muy bien pero tienes que apuntarte
a baloncesto o algún tipo de cosa así y
yo siempre fui muy cabezona le dije mira
no lo siento mucho mamá pero es que yo
quiero apuntarme aquí yo quiero que me
apuntes que yo que me apunté es quiero
que me apuntes total que al final me
hizo caso me apunto no sólo a solfeo
sino que hice piano y bueno y más tarde
empecé a hacer otras cosas relacionadas
con la música eso que bueno en el
colegio siempre me tenía que sentar solo
sola porque los niños no querían
sentarse conmigo porque decían que era
como una radio porque pasaba día
cantando y eso que los seis años se
preguntan tú qué quieres ser de mayor la
típica pregunta que te hacen cuando
empiezas la primaria y bueno había el
típico niño que decía yo quiero ser
astronauta yo quiero ser bombero yo
quiero ser policía y bueno cuando me
preguntaron a mí yo evidentemente la que
más claro lo tenía yo quería ser
cantante bueno pues el tema es qué
fueron pasando los años y bueno la
música siempre estuvo en mi vida yo
llegaba a casa después del colegio
después de las clases de música de las
clases de piano y me ponía escucharse de
escuchar la radio todo lo que pudiera
pasar unos años y cuando empieza la
secundaria te vuelven a preguntar qué
quieres ser de mayor y yo tuve la suerte
de ir al mismo colegio desde los 3 hasta
los 16 qué pasa que la misma persona que
había dicho que quería ser astronauta y
a los 6 años les parecía normal que
quisiera ser astronauta a los 13 dijo ay
bueno yo que creo que es quiero ser
abogado después al policía pues creo que
quería ser no sé contable no me acuerdo
exactamente pero a mí me volvieron a
preguntar y yo dije que quería ser
cantante lo que pasa que las reacciones
fue diferente a los 6 años a todo el
mundo le parecía completamente normal
que alguien quisiera ser cantante pero a
los 13 pues se rieron de mí porque bueno
era como que no era real
y entonces pues bueno como que me siento
un poco mal porque incluso la profesora
me dijo mira yo creo cecilia que
tendrías que plantearte lo y plantearte
qué bueno una carrera profesional normal
que lo de cantante está muy bien que lo
de soñar está muy guay pero que la gente
trabaja de otras cosas fueron pasando
los años y a las clases de piano y
solfeo le sumé de las clases de teatro
musical de técnicas vocales de mil cosas
más y todas mis horas libres las pasaba
con algo relacionado con la música monté
mis primeras bandas compuse mis primeras
canciones hice un montón de cosas
relacionadas con la música pero el tema
es que en la carrera universitaria me
seguía pasando lo mismo cuando yo decía
que quería ser cantante estudiando
visuales todo el mundo me verano
haciendo bueno entonces qué haces aquí y
por qué estás tan loca no que quieres
algo que parece tan surrealista bueno
terminado todo esto terminada la carrera
y pasado todo este mal triángulo puede
decir que yo creo que al final si tú
crees en lo que haces y realmente estás
convencido trabajas muchísimo y no dejas
de soñar no tienes que dejar que los
otros te maten la ilusión puede ser
exactamente lo que quieras
y aquí está el claro ejemplo que ahora
me dedico a la música y aveces todavía
me preguntan pero realmente en qué
trabajas no no soy cantante
gracias
[Aplausos]
y es cierto
servir
s agua agua y desborde
[Música]
es debido
que será venganza venir no ser son
benítez
esas
[Música]
ah
[Aplausos]
[Música]
i
[Aplausos]
[Música]
o
i
he seguido
[Música]
muchísimas gracias
vamos a hacer el último tema para cerrar
el evento y os pido por favor un flauta
un fuerte aplauso no sería hablar para
francisco porque vienes pensamientos de
parís
[Aplausos]
mi vida
[Música]
un dólar
no antes
descansando
las hermanas
durban
d
pagar vivo y el sol
[Música]
dorado
mientras más
sí no
las hermanas
como de lugar
para volar
huele que yo soy bueno
we can cómo es eso
bueno
[Música]
[Aplausos]
seguro
[Música]
ahora nunca llevó a construir
no te pongas
y amoratado
ah
[Música]